au milieu des cordes et des archers tout
est bien orchestré Lucile Sanders
installé son atelier Lucil luth en
octobre 2021 à molette à travers sa
profession de litière l'artisane de 31
ans fabrique et restaure des instruments
à cordes frotter violon alto violoncelle
et contrebasse un travail de précision
sur le bois et l'acoustique de l'objet
vous voulez faire quelque chose dans la
musique mais je voulais pas que ce soit
uniquement musical mais je savais aussi
que je voulais faire quelque chose dans
le manuel dans le travail des mains et
vraiment ce métier c'est ce qui associe
parfaitement les deux lors de la
conception d'un instrument les planches
d'épicières et d'érable arrivent brut
chez Lucile elles sont ensuite signées
et sculptés pour obtenir la forme voulue
chaque élément est ajusté au millimètre
près exigeant dextérité et patience sur
ce violoncelle en réparation cette pièce
doit être taillée à l'aide d'un canif
pour épouser parfaitement la forme de la
voûte
là c'est un instrument neuf donc c'est
vraiment quasiment complètement lisse
mais sur un instrument ancien avec la
pression des cordes ça aura pu se
creuser justement là où il y avait les
pieds du chalet son puissant ou
chaleureux incrustation de nacre et
couleur de vernis chaque objet est
confectionné sur mesure un violon et
finalisé en trois mois environ dans cet
atelier concevoir les instruments c'est
vraiment ce que je préfère parce que
déjà je peux répondre à une demande
spécifique et puis je peux y mettre
vraiment tout moi même tout mon âme mon
amour aussi et faire des choses qui
sortent aussi de l'ordinaire
[Musique]
joueuse de violon depuis l'âge de 7 ans
cette passionnée de musique ne compte
pas ses heures passées dans l'atelier
pour le plaisir d'inventer ou de
redonner vie un instrument de famille
oubliée dans un grenier Ier
[Musique]